foreign
foreign foreign
the three Muslims we're joined here with
definitely not Flavia once again how you
doing
guys
what about your name I don't know if we
discussed this last time it just slipped
my mind but why are you definitely not
Flavia
um well it was because not flavi was
taken so I was like okay we're gonna do
definitely instead
this reminds me of like people's like
Tumblr usernames back then yeah it's not
very creative but you know I kind of
regret using my name online but what can
we do now
you know some sisters like asked like DM
does asking is that really her last like
her first name and we were like yeah
that's dead as her first name
gives us alums he couldn't make it right
now because it's super late for him
um but regardless uh Rami what do you
think of the title of today's stream
um well I didn't even read it bro what's
the title oh my God bro today we are
talking about do women need education oh
okay I see super super loaded question
but uh that's why we have sister love
you here
um so before we go in do you have
anything that you want to mention or to
the viewers anything like that
um
hello that question was for sister
Flavia oh my God
if I read the title so I'm like
it's all good bro you guys can both
answer it do I have anything to mention
about the subject or anything at all
um
I think that it's been talked about on
on Tick Tock side
for a while now I don't even know why
it's a discussion but apparently it is
um
subhanallah
okay alhamdulillah so anyone that made
it this far smash that like button
before we go in many things to talk
about today so number one we're going to
talk about women's education some of the
things going on today in the marriage
Market because men and women both
clearly have different expectations from
the other gender and they think that we
require very similar things that's not
the case oftentimes
um should a woman get education should
she not what her intentions for getting
the education
um and so on and so forth so before we
even go into it Rami do you want us to
do you want to give us like a very clear
like Islamic answer to this in a
nutshell like can women have a right to
an education because many people are
bothered by the idea that women are
going to seek education
yeah so the rights to education is
something that is is not only given to
people but encouraged for people
um and if you look at uh it's funny her
name I believe her name is Ashley shifa
um but it was either her another sister
uh these are sahabiya right so in the
time of um
who appointed her as like a chief
um kind of medical advisor or a doctor
or something at the time because she was
very well versed in medicine
um so you know if um can he could
utilize a woman's education in that way
rather than saying you know bring a man
or whatever then why should we
discourage women from learning Islam you
know
the topic of enjoying good and
forbidding evil and and seeking
knowledge is an obligation upon everyone
including women and some people might
say that that's only in the religion I
would say first and foremost it is in
the religion 100 but it's not exclusive
to the religion right there are many
women
many women throughout history like shifa
um who I mentioned got an education and
at the very least education is like it's
a loaded thing what are we talking about
physics talking about mathematics you're
talking about business administration
what are we talking about if someone
wants to say that
you know maybe there are certain fields
of women uh shouldn't go into that is
one that's understandable you know in
the western uh context but to say that
you know they don't have the right to or
they should not have the ability to
um regardless of circumstance situation
or whatever I think is a little a little
too much it's a little too loaded
um there are you know certain cases like
if the woman is married and her husband
doesn't want her to work you know I can
understand that
um but that's you know between the the
man and the husband
LGBT uh TV is getting TV man so no no we
know what you mean bro very well bro
just like look here for that I think
that in Islam and specifically in many
fields like for example if you have a
wife and she's giving labor you wouldn't
want her to have let's say a male
gynecologist you know what I mean
um it goes without saying but I know
like no that doesn't necessitate that
every woman now needs to become in stem
because we need that many female
gynecologists you know what I mean yeah
we're a nuanced topic and I think that
people are coming at it too black and
white some people are in one extreme
saying that women should literally
dedicate their lives to a career get all
these useless degrees like you know
gender studies or whatever they don't
need that but then the extreme thing
that women actually should not study at
all and I think it's a very nuanced
topic so it's just what do you think
about all that I think that the brothers
that tell us that education is a need to
know that we shouldn't go to university
I think they come from a certain
perspective of that they think that all
of us who are going to go to university
are going to be raging feminists and
we're going to come out not wanting any
kids not wanting to get married et
cetera et cetera because of they
cherry-picked these situations where
that does happen
but in reality you go to the Masala in
the University or in the college every
single musama wants to get married
99.9 of all conversations are
what are we gonna do to get made
we always talk about it it's not like we
don't want to right
sometimes like our parents want us to
pursue a higher education just in case
and or we want to pursue something just
in case but at the end of the day mainly
for all Muslims
it's because like we all just want to
get married right
do you think that's the case for most of
us specifically because I think that for
non-muslim women I've seen a lot of them
kind of get lost in the sauce but then
for most of us you all know very clearly
how important it is to have marriage
yeah I think that it's super super
different between non-muslims and
Muslims because if you ask their purpose
of studying to a Muslim versus a
non-muslim
they're gonna have completely different
answers you know the Muslim from what
I've seen tends to be oh because I want
to have something to fall back on and
for the non-muslims it's usually
oh I just want to pursue education and I
want to be like a boss babe or whatever
they want to call themselves you know
and um like work for myself or you know
et cetera et cetera so I think we have
completely different standards and goals
and I think some brothers are you know
putting us into the same category when
we're not
um okay that was very well put so my my
first question today is going to be what
are your thoughts about a man's
perspective on a woman's marriage
ability we can call it uh based on her
education so do you think that it
increases her chances of being a
suitable candidate to a man the average
man obviously all else being equal do
you think it decreases it or do you
think it has like no impact
um
honestly
I think that
perhaps
I guess for some men it does kind of
scare them away because you know since
they do group us into the same category
as non-muslims they're going to be like
oh so she has a higher education she's
going to divorce me and run away you
know and she's not going to take the
marriage seriously because she can just
dip whenever right because she does have
her own job she has her own
responsibilities Etc et cetera but
um I don't think the brothers should
think this way right I don't think that
anyone should think this way because you
are putting us in the category like I
said before of non-muslims which is very
insulting to be honest with you and B
because that's not the reality of things
we like most of us we do want to get
settled down
right and I guess it just depends on
every man and their comfortability but I
don't think that any man should be
scared of marrying a girl with you know
higher knowledge because it's
it's I was actually having a
conversation with my dad about this the
other day but he was he's told me I
don't want to marry someone I don't I
didn't want to marry someone who didn't
pursue anything in their life because I
don't want to talk to a brick wall right
I don't want to talk to someone who just
looks pretty and then they have nothing
you know to tell me no stories nothing
so
around me bro what's on your mind
um I just want to get this out of the
way because I've been laughing about it
for the last like 10 minutes come on all
right go someone I know somebody out
there is going to take my man and a
husband uh statement and say that I said
that on purpose because only the man
gets the choice
you got a joke
says
on the on the actual topic
um I I think it really depends on the
situation and like the sister mentioned
the person's intention and um what they
like to do I don't think it it's not
like it's not like someone where it's
not like something where you can look at
it and and draw any conclusion like if
you if you if you're vetting a guy or or
a woman and they were married before and
you keep hearing that they kept like
hitting and being their partner that's
something you could draw a conclusion
from okay I should stay awake because
they're clearly aggressive or at least
at some point where and I don't want to
take that risk but if someone if someone
comes and says oh I studied you know uh
psychology or or whatever the field as a
study medicine or law
okay well law is a different story I
don't talk about that but you know I
studied this field you know that's not
something you can draw a conclusion from
so I think everyone needs to use their
discretion and be mature adults and look
at the person that they're talking to if
this person is like gloating and
boasting yeah I got this degree and I
got that degree and I'm so you know uh
professional and academic and blah blah
blah you know then you could look beyond
that and say okay this person seems
maybe a little too hotty a little too
arrogant a little too proud of their
degrees they put too much value in their
education you know especially in a
secular world but if you look at a
person like yeah I did this I studied
this and you see they're a good person
with good morals and good character and
conduct and good religion and that stuff
then why would you turn that person away
um I think the difference is not between
getting a degree and getting education
and not I think the difference should be
between if they are basically arrogant
or a bad in character or have a
liberalized western mindset or if they
have a you know an Islamic mindset or
the difference should be you know are
they are they coherent or are they
stupid I wouldn't want to marry a dumb
woman I don't think a woman would want
to marry a dumb man either
um I don't think people want to marry
them people in general uh so it doesn't
really have to do much with
if having a degree or not but more so
being
um a coherent uh conducive person in
life so
um my maybe my answer would have been
different a year ago but my wife has a
degree in marketing economics and that
has helped me tremendously
um and I think many brothers can even my
my friend I'm not gonna say his name but
he's on Tick Tock his wife studies
psychology that helped him tremendously
in his dawah as well so if you're gonna
choose a partner why not choose someone
who has a little more Edge over somebody
else if they can benefit you
and did you mean Edge as a shortened
form of Education or no I I actually
meant Edge like they have something over
somebody else but bro I thought you you
were going to slide that in bro
discreetly no no no no so let's talk
about some of the reasons it was
wonderful what both of you said but we
should talk about some of the reasons
that men specifically do fear and are
intimidated by this like sister father
was mentioning
um so some of the arguments that I hear
very often are it takes a certain
relative degree of disagreeability to
make it an education now if you have
someone like that as a wife their fear
is that they wouldn't necessarily be as
feminine and femininity is something
that men at least masculine men would
differ correct they find that attractive
and suitable so what would you say to
that
I think that is a very boring lifestyle
and person to have beside you if they
are constantly agreeing with everything
you have to say
or everything you do
I'm sorry but are you thinking there's a
woman or
I'm saying I'm saying like both men and
women if they agree all the time like
it's not
it's not like bad to have disagreements
um like right but
of course don't disagree on something
that's like completely
dumb like I don't know if he likes a
certain card don't say oh my gosh so
ugly like you know don't have those itty
bitty weird disagreements but if you
guys have General disagreements
about I don't know
sorts of things and the aspects of
politics I don't know anything it's okay
to have a back and forth right the main
thing that needs to be there is Islam
and that you guys aren't disagreeing on
Islam that's the only thing that matters
basically
hmm
fair enough Rami what do you think
um I had an answer then I forgot the
question okay so the question is women
require a certain degree of disagreement
disagreeability not just women but just
men and women in general who basically
uh progress through like the upper
echelons of Education in the workforce
in today's society right so that a lot
of men think that this will make their
women or women folk more masculine
um a little bit more disagreeable and
you know Sister Flavio was talking about
like where we draw the line obviously
she shouldn't disagree with Islamic
things but just in general this
heightened disagreeability like a
character trait yeah yeah so firstly I'm
interested in why they draw that
conclusion that going through the
education system kind of produces
disagreeable people I would say there
are many you know even women in the
workforce who went through educations
are still very agreeable and feminine in
nature I don't think go through an
education necessitates that they would
come out this you know disagreeable
monster I think that's a little extreme
to say but regardless like the sister
was saying disagreements are not bad in
the you know themselves
um
if if you have a case where you know a
man is making a big decision and his
wife weighs in there's nothing wrong
with that and let me give an example
this is not really indecision but the
process tell him he actually went to one
of his wives
um basically he saw a dream that he was
going to do Hajj with the sahaba I'm
sure people are familiar with the story
and when he got there the uh I believe
the pagans didn't let them in so they
weren't able to do Hajj so people kind
of I don't want to say lost faith but
they kind of grew a little like upset
depressed like you're supposed to come
all the way here and do it you know do a
Hajj what happened said I just saw a
dream we were doing it didn't have
to be this year you know
um so they the prophet sallam said you
know
um shave your heads and do this and that
and well yeah he said shave your heads
and a lot of the animals and do all that
stuff still and they wouldn't really
listen they were kind of distraught he
went back to one of his wives
and he asked for advice and you know she
gave him advice she said start shaving
your hair and kind of installing the
animals they will follow you on that so
he did that and it worked they did it
you know so you have the husband the
prophet peace and blessing be upon him
who none of us are better than being
advised by his wife you know so
disagreeability or her having an opinion
or her stating something is not a bad
trait I would like the sister said I
would not want a woman that would 100
back my decisions unless my decisions
were final right and I think that's the
the straw because people fall into an
extremes of or if they if she disagrees
with this then it's a problem because
she's always going to disagree with
everything but that's not necessarily
true there are some things that you know
if you what if you're wrong she should
disagree with you and you should hope to
have a partner that would look at you
and say that's silly that's dumb that's
that's not going to work you know I was
very
harsh I think in my approach to women
Once Upon a Time and my wife told me
that this stuff doesn't work and I
realized you know through speaking with
her it doesn't work and now when I take
that into that way it comes it's
completely changed I think alhamdulillah
it's had a much better result and that
will translate I think that everybody
else's life if once they get married a
lot of people out there you know they're
very Stern like red pill mucho Macho
even talking to women then they get
married and like everything changes
that's just that's just how life goes
because we when we hear about women
through the lens of men you know we get
a masculine perspective you know the
whole thing about you know don't learn
how to fish from a fish learn from a
fisherman kind of thing is it's vice
versa as well you know if you want to
learn how to treat a woman you actually
you you shouldn't um you shouldn't take
it from the people who have never had a
good you know a success story with a
woman basically we've only been
heartbroken in that stuff you know it's
only the men with the worst experiences
that are propagating the stuff so maybe
you shouldn't listen to them
um very well put bro now the next thing
I hear a lot is there's a Hadith where
the Prophet saw mentions that a man's
responsibility and obligation in the
eyes of Allah is to take care and
protect his family his wife so on and so
forth and then for the wife it's the
home
so the the problem that I see a lot of
men equating this to is if she has a
career if she if she works a job then
she's kind of diffusing her
responsibility from the house now Sister
flavi what do you think about that
sorry
on the left
and go for Asia
[Music]
bro who the hell is this let me pin this
comment right now sorry okay I don't
know what is this
[Laughter]
I don't even know why you guys are
laughing at that like what does that
even mean you know I told yo I told you
guys before the stream that y'all are so
zoomed in
I'm literally so small like look at this
it's ridiculous
sorry uh could you repeat the question
yeah okay Bismillah so I was saying that
when it comes to
um there's a Hadith where the Prophet
saw mentions that a man's responsibility
is to protect and provide for and
maintain his family his wives his kids
and for a woman the obligation in laws
of Allah is to
protect and defend his honor when he's
not there but just to maintain the home
and focus on the as in like an
obligation in the eyes of Allah but at
the same time men are now equating this
to this sense of her defusing
responsibility from her obligation by
Allah uh when she picks a career or a
job or something like that so what do
you have to say about that
I think that
that when
if men are saying that or
I think that's the fear kicking in again
saying oh my wife is going to be more
masculine if she knows more than me or
she has a degree
she you can have a talk with her before
you get married asking her if she does
want to work or not right most of us
don't want to work most of us
I'm going to be quite Frank with you
guys most of us don't want to work
so
the only reason why we're pursuing a
higher education whether we have
different reasons for that it's for us
for our family for the future
but the main reason that I hear is that
we don't live in a Utopia we don't live
in an Islamic State with a Khalifa who
has you know these set of rules saying
that
you know if a woman isn't working she
has to be legally provided for
by her madams which would make us feel
safer and I 100 assure all the brothers
here that if we had that sort of system
all the sisters or there would be
majority of sisters would you know stay
at home
do their duties because they'd feel safe
right they feel safe at all times
but unfortunately we don't live in that
Utopia that world so
we want to pursue higher education just
in case
I like that you said Utopia but
coincidentally that's what Islam stands
for but Islam is not being practiced in
the correct Islamic framework in the
west
um and the problem is I strongly believe
it's our fault as men that we have
failed I've spoken to a brother Gabriel
aramani so many times about this that
this whole feminism independent movement
that you see it's because men failed
their responsibility in the first place
by not making sure that we're taking
care of all our Affairs that women now
kind of felt like they were oppressed or
they were abused or they were not having
their rights withheld such as being
provided for being protected for
um maybe they can't go back to the Wale
whatever the case is that now there's
almost like this reactionary movement
that they need to take care of
themselves and no one else will
um what do you think about that yeah um
obviously you know Allah he's prescribed
certain laws in in ways of living for us
uh for a reason so anything less than
that is going to cause problems you know
um there's a reason the uh kharifa is in
charge of taking care of those who
cannot take care of themselves that's
why um
introduced um uh you know basically
benefits that people get when they have
children
and this you know it's from a well-known
story uh so but I do but I do think
there's a degree of Truth to what the
brothers say because it's not so much
about education now now it's about
working right a woman can get an
education and not work in that field or
any field that's you know possible and
she can retain and you know keep
learning whatever she studied in that's
fine but in going out and working you
know this could be a problem
because if they do have kids think about
it you know I don't want to say from the
child's perspective but think about the
kid you know she gets what six months a
year
um you know after giving birth to be
with the kid and that's it
or maybe two years and then that's it
you throw them under a nanny and and
then the mom and the dad are working you
know that's very destructive for a kid
and you don't know which nanny is taking
care of them you don't know like you
might find them on uh some you know
nanny.net or something like that you
don't know if they're good what they're
going to be teaching your kid
and if they're going to be good to them
so there is a responsibility for the
mother to take care of the the kids to
nurture them and because Allah created
them you know with more empathy
um that's just naturally how they are
and that's a beautiful thing
um so
um you know if if a man does tell his
wife you know you need to leave your job
and stay home and take care of the kid
she should listen to him 100 and I I
generally think like if women want to
work you know if they need to work
that's one thing right the school has to
say that's permissible but if they want
to work and they they forsake their
children that they call they they
forsake their children just basically to
go work to make extra money just for
themselves that's not something that's
okay
hmm 100 okay now this brings me to my
next question that I wanted to ask
sister Flavia when you and I'm assuming
you're still single right so should we
should we go like CVV sent to your DMs
or how does that work
are you are you looking or are you just
not interested at the moment
um well my one thing was that I have my
mom
[Music]
start looking
and I didn't expect it to be this early
so
like they found out on accident or
somebody snitched on me I don't know how
it went I don't know if they're actually
telling me the truth but
um somebody found out in my family that
I did Tick Tock and they saw me with the
nakab and they saw me with the hijab and
they all kind of freaked out and so what
you're trying to say is you're single
ready to mingle exactly the permissible
way so guys um this brings me to my next
question so sister flavi let's say
you're looking at a man's potential as a
candidate if you want to marry you does
education or anything like that for him
uh change anything about his suitability
in your eyes or are you more of like you
just care about income
I do care about
care about I can't lie I do
um and I guess that's because the way
I've been raised and I do like to have
intellectual talks I'm not saying that
you know men who just make a ton of
money aren't you know intellectual but
I would personally want someone who does
have an education just in case anything
you know goes wrong because I know
businesses and you know being Your Own
Boss you know things can go wrong right
so I would want someone with an
education
um so in my opinion it does kind of Step
It Up of course depending on the
depending on the degree because gender
studies is like yeah I kind of
overlooked that yeah I don't mean what
about you let's say you are single
um you're not you're married well let's
say you're looking for a second wife
um and let's say you are trying to
screen
um you know potential wifey let's say
she has a degree versus she doesn't have
a degree how does this impact her
credibility to you it literally does not
impact her at all and that's what I was
trying to say with my first answer that
what effect okay she has a degree in I
don't know business administration or or
some kind of management role or
something okay she's not gonna manage
the house
um so as long as she knows that hold us
no problem if she thinks she's going to
come and start managing everything okay
no obviously it's not going to work but
if she has that degree and uses it to
like you know manage the the children or
manage like a business or a side hustle
we have or manage your own kind of you
know drops I don't say Drop Shipping
some scholarships but you know whatever
uh it's permissible for her okay go for
it it's not a problem but um because
it's not a marker for good or bad per se
it depends on the person
so no doubt into our eyes and I want to
agree with the the it doesn't increase
our marriage ability to us
um depending on the man it might be a
cultural norm for example a lot of Daisy
households I know this for a fact they
require their wife to be super high
educated in like upper you know higher
education not just like high school not
just undergrad like I'm talking grad
school and even more and the parents
look for that as a criteria as a
requirement as an obligation if she
cannot withhold that then she's
disqualified automatically
um but just letting you all know from
our point of view as men this doesn't
affect us whatsoever like if she has an
education or not
um so I agree with both around me um so
sister Olivia what are you looking for
aside from education then in a potential
man
um really looking for someone who has
a passion in giving dawa especially
because that's one of my main goals in
life
um like I've set it out to convert
people in my country like or at least
spread the message of a Sim you know in
my
native area so that you know because
there's a lot of misconceptions about
some of that so if my husband isn't
willing to come with me and do that or
my future husband's right my husband
isn't willing to do that then that's a
really really big down for me so dawa
and Islamic knowledge is um
really really up there for me
okay anything else that you want to
mention
um obviously the education part and you
know you know uh that he can provide for
me and make me feel comfortable and
stuff
um
also that he's comfortable with my
family you know not being Muslim and
everything he's willing to be soft with
them
um also educate them on Islam with me
do you want a feminine man like everyone
has their own preferences I'm just
trying to make your life easier when
they DM you okay okay I see
um honestly it's obviously
as a mussama
we gotta have a masculine man not a red
pill guy definitely not a red pill just
like an islamically
Muslim
sorry masculine islamically Muslim man
you heard yes an islamically masculine
man I'm sorry islamically masking that's
that's based I like that
um no brother around me what other
things do you look for
um aside from her let's say having an
attitude of not managing the house and
being cooperative uh what else do you
look for
um well the best advice is always the
advice of the Prophet Muhammad he said
basically if you want to be successful
marry for religion uh and another Hadith
he mentions religion and and good you
know character mannerisms so those are
the two most important things and the
reason is very clear if they have good
character then no matter what the
situation is insha Allah most of the
time you and them if you both have a
good character will be able to defuse it
and deal with it in a rational and
mature way
um rather if they have bad character you
will you know even if she's a woman
sometimes she'll hit you she'll yell
she'll scream she'll you know be
manipulative she'll lose her mind
sometimes you know and same thing with
guys sometimes they'll they'll lose
their mind and walk out on you and
threaten divorce and all these crazy
things uh which we um you know we need
to avoid and the religion because you
know if they fear Allah even if they
hate you they're not going to be about
you because they know you know you have
right over them and vice versa so those
are the best things to look for if you
want more specifics um I don't really
like answering these questions because
specifics really at that point depends
on the person because if I'm a person
who really needs to be catered For or
catered to
um then I would look for a woman who can
do that and if I'm a person that doesn't
really need to be catered to but need
someone who you know I can I can kind of
walk through my problems and you know we
could talk it out and she can give me
some advice and I could you know run my
ideas Pastor or something then I would
look for that so it depends on a person
bro I know you don't want to want to go
specific right now I'm gonna go even
more specific but I promise relevant bro
so sister Flavia mentioned something
like let's say masculinity or a degree
these things are binary you either have
it or you don't sure there's like
degrees to how far you can have these
things but either you have it or you
don't you you mentioned Dean how do you
measure something like that as a man
because a lot of sisters might be
hearing this and be like am I
islamically on point am I not so where
do you draw your I guess basic
fundamental uh p's and q's on the
um well there's a surface level and then
the deeper level the surface levels
things like you know as from from a mass
perspective perspective you know if
she's if she's wearing a hijab if she's
praying her Salah
um
if she passed the month of Ramadan no
these these basic Circle surface level
things that you could see deeper is how
much Islamic knowledge does she actually
have is she able to quote the Quran she
able to quote the prophet saws and then
deeper and deeper would be how does she
treat her parents you know what's her
modesty level in front of you speaking
with you you know is she like day two
and she's super out there flirtatious or
is she still you know keeping herself
preserved
um uh because she's not you know had
fear yeah and vice versa these things
are all things you need to watch out for
I think people need to develop a lot of
basic skills nowadays including being
observant
when you really really you know observe
things and think rationally and
critically about them
um and don't get hooked on the idea of
oh I want to be married or be married to
this person you will end up saving
yourself from a lot of of trouble
um
someone wrote that you went too deep Bro
I don't know about that
um the fire does have W RIS I don't know
I'm gonna act like I don't know what
that means for the purposes of Haya the
stream turned into the bachelor's is
that like a TV show or what
I don't know what that is
does sister Flavio feel comfortable oh
that should be like the first thing that
we ask her do you feel comfortable being
here with us yes I do are you here
against your own will
no there's no guns being pointed out my
head guys okay guys speak education not
marriage
it just goes to show how everything
comes back to marriage eventually
um so we do have a super chat on me if
you want to address this
um oh my God this guy how old is sister
falavia and how much older would she
like her husband to be maybe younger
question mark eye emojis
um
this right here
stop being thirsty anyway yeah I mean
what's wrong with you people honestly
like if you can't be normal then just
leave the Stream
um you know fear Allah seriously fear
Allah
because sister fluffy she didn't even
answer that question
no when it comes to younger guys I feel
like that's just for me the dynamic kind
of goes off
okay listen I'm not trying to like
offend anyone who has you know who's
younger in age than their spouse or
whatever but
when if I look at myself and I'm in a
major I'm a little bit older it's always
going to be in my brain I can't lie it's
it won't go up it won't go out and I
guess that has to do with like the
dynamic of my family because none of my
um my parents my mom she's younger than
my dad my grandparents same thing
just goes on and on and on and on back
so I guess it's just a dynamic but yeah
okay
all right so now my next question for
both of you guys is going to be this
that let's say you have a scenario where
there is a man who is looking for a
potential wife right and he actually is
considering getting with a woman
she's currently in school
now the woman irregardless of if she
wants to finish or not what do you think
first around me his approach should be
on this I know it's gonna definitely
differ person to person so No One's
Gonna deny that some men would want her
to finish some men might prefer her not
to finish and at the end of the day it's
her right if she wants to finish or not
but how would you answer that because
there's always a better option in terms
of what we should do
so just so I get the question straight
she's in school still has you know time
to go okay
um she's actually interested in marrying
the brother and he intends on marrying
her but school might be in the way maybe
this is a concern for him maybe it's not
okay well I mean Nothing is Stopping
nikai no Nothing is Stopping them from
sitting in uh you know agreeing on a
Maher sitting with tawali and two
witnesses and
um writing the marriage contract and
signing off Nothing is Stopping them
from that not school not work nothing
and nothing should be at least in that
case uh you can do the Nika and and she
can finish school while you guys are
married and I shouldn't stop you guys
and um if you guys are same in the same
area then she could even live with you
and still go to school you know
um generally speaking again depends on
the situation but there's nothing
holding people back from that now if the
man specifically has a problem with that
and that's something they need to talk
about before they get married
um and maybe amongst other things but
generally speaking it shouldn't hold
anyone back the only people in that
situation school is not holding them
back by the way the only people holding
them back usually are the parents oh my
God why you want to get married you're
only you're only 25 years old you know
you have three years of University left
because you're going to be a doctor
um what are you waiting for it's like
bro what what are you talking about I'm
getting my Nika I'm it's Halal I'm
allowed to be with this person you can
even still live with your parents and be
married to someone just the problem is a
lot of parents do not make it easy for
their kids to get married and that's a
shame I'm going on that bro because I
feel like what you said was spot on that
not only is it going to be no impact on
their school education most of the time
but sometimes it might actually benefit
them
help them lower the Gaze help them
protect the private parts as a law
obligates us so what do you think about
that yeah I mean absolutely I mean if
you think there's fitna in the west and
universities Fitness Central you have a
bunch of people who are at the the
absolute like height and peak of their
sexual hormonal Drive they are their
bodies telling them oh I need to do this
and that and procreate and whatever you
know so not being married in that
situation is only going to make it
easier to do something Haram now
obviously the Haram should be very
difficult you know back in the day it
was difficult to go to someone's place
or go somewhere in kimizina it was
difficult nowadays unfortunately it's
very very easy and the Haram is very
easy and the Halal is very difficult
that's something that is horrible so
you're going to fit in a Central
University and you're seeing all these
people and you're feeling all these
emotions and especially you know as a
man there's a huge for women as well I
don't people think there isn't but man
that drive that libido is so much
greater seeing whatever he's seeing you
know he looks down he sees a magazine of
a woman on the floor he looks to the
left he sees the bus driving by with the
woman on it it looks you know sitting in
class the professor is a woman or
something you know it's it's difficult
so being married at least you know
you're going to feel these feelings
about the end of the day you come home
to your loving wife you get to spend
time with her and you know
uh do you know what you need to do as a
man uh to feel you know good and
continue going
beautiful bro I love my brother because
sister flavi what do you think about
that
I think
the scenario of when you know the guy
says you know get out of University like
you don't need to pursue this higher
education and stuff
it kind of I mean at least to me it
raises red flags
oh here we go it raises so many red
flags
um and that's because like you know I
guess
you know we're not protected here as
women in the west right not very
protected if I knew that I could fall
back on anyone on any of you know my
maharams to just provide for me again I
would 100 just be like okay I'm out of
school I'm just gonna pursue Islamic
education that's it
but um
I think that they say this a lot of the
times because they say
you know University causes fitna and you
being there you're a fitna uh et cetera
Etc but
I mean we're in if you're in full hijab
and you're going to University lowering
your gaze
we don't have all women's universities
over here in the west what can we do
right
I agree with that
um before I go to my next question
someone wrote my GPS 0.47 would you say
that was good
look at our eyes lit up
she's like next
all right next I'm 18 and I live in
Ottawa but failed math in uni
um I think the 18 is already like she
doesn't go with younger
and then the math what do you think
about that is there any hope
yeah no you have to be peek at math my
father does not like
that's like the first question the world
is going to ask
yeah
um Brother Ali writes the sooner the
better
you never know how much time you have
may Allah bless us with a long life
Allah I mean but we do not have the
guarantee of tomorrow
we need universities only from Muslims
like the Christians do this is what you
were saying we don't have that
unfortunately so it's not much we could
do with that
um okay cool next question is let's say
now the sister is
considering considering that maybe this
man that she found is like a really good
Potential Prospect and no scarcity
mentality I'm not talking about that I'm
talking objectively he is like the catch
of all catches and she has let's say I
don't know like four five six years left
in education so it's not even like all
right let me just finish in like a
couple months or like a year
um now the sister is considering let's
say leaving school for him and trusting
that you know what Bismillah I'm gonna
praise Takara he got my back I don't
have to worry about it and
main long story short she's not even
that much progressed in her education so
she wants to start again it's only like
she's maybe like just 10 in five percent
in so what advice would you give to
sister
um
I would tell her you know if she prayed
the Sahara she has a good feeling about
it she hasn't seen any red flags this
brother is educated islamically
and he can provide for her
why not just
just go for it
I know my dad if he he listens to this
he's probably gonna be like five year
crazy tell her to pursue her education
I mean it just depends on everyone's
goals right it's case-by-case scenario
and how comfortable she is how does how
does Bubba feel about coming on the
stream next time I think we talked about
that last time right yeah I don't know
um I haven't but he is definitely down
like he's done you're not even done you
didn't even you're lofting on this
because we we have Sunny fast who's
another YouTuber and his mom comes to
Christian and the discourses are very
like amusing hearing her perspective as
like a Christian mom who's like kind of
born again like she came into it
recently challenging some of her views
and just talking to her
yeah my dad could probably give some
some of his
his hot takes on religion and stuff he's
not really a Christian but he doesn't
believe in God he's a deist so
be some interesting conversations
inshallah guys comment if you want that
no next uh question Rami where do you
think that the best places to find a
religious traditional wife would be I
know what I'm going to answer but I want
you to go first
um I don't I don't know I don't I don't
think there's there's no place that I
know of where it's like you can just go
and find a traditional wife like you
can't just go to like the traditional
wife store and you know take your pick
it's kind of like a diamond you you dig
you dig you dig eventually you find one
in the spot
um yeah there are better places than
others
I don't know why my camera keeps
flashing my butt
um you shouldn't go to the mall looking
for a wife but you know you can go to
the Masjid you can go to um
the mall is I mean
I I think generally the quality of the
people at the mall would not be as good
as the quality of the people like the
Masjid
you know for example I'm not saying the
mall is bad I'm sure people got married
that way
but this isn't I would say the ideal way
to find someone I think that if you're
going to look for someone if you have
that intention let me fix this then it
should you should you know uh start in
the right place start in the Masjid
start not working go to your your good
believing friends who are married and
see if they know anyone
okay okay alhamdulillah
um the advice that I always give people
including my clients whenever they ask
me is Allah says in the Quran that good
men are safe for good women and good
women are safe for Good Men bad men are
safe for bad women and bad women are
safe for bad men so if you can get
yourself to a point where you've
achieved a certain level of not just
religiosity but spirituality talk about
closeness to Allah consciousness of
Allah and you keep praying and making
Dua to Allah you're on point then
eventually insha Allah the woman will
enter your life in a way that you can't
even imagine like it might be just bump
into her at like Whole Foods you know
because Whole Foods they got wholesome
women not the Romney's saying uh maybe
it's like I don't know like a DM or
something like it's so coincidental but
we know nothing happens by coincidence
and I think that that would be the
approach it's not necessarily where do
you find them but what should you do for
them to find you and for Allah to put
them in your life
get ready for that blurry fade oh so
this is this is one of my one of my
close friends who I'm gonna visit he's a
barber inshallah
from the states
um someone writes it shouldn't be this
difficult for people to get married
subhanallah it shouldn't be but this is
kind of what it's come to and there's
many reasons namely what brother Rami
has said that parents are a lot of time
making it difficult
um another reason is people have
unrealistic expectations of the marriage
market so one thing that I hear from a
lot of women is he needs to have x y z
XYZ being something that is almost
impossible to find not that it's you
know like fully impossible but it's it's
almost unreasonable and then for men
for them they expect a lot of these
things in in Muslims today that it's
very rare to come across now it doesn't
mean that you can't have these standards
I think it's very important to have
standards in life especially when it
comes to marriage and education like
sister flavi was saying but there has to
be that fine line between at one point
am I going to compromise my standards
for like settling you know what I mean
like it's like you can think of it like
a graph with like two lines and one of
them is like your standards and one of
them is like okay when you're gonna
basically cash in your chips and if you
want to just die on that hill of like
having hundred thousand percent
standards and unrealistic you're not
gonna find anyone but then in The Other
Extreme if you have no standards you can
find someone literally tomorrow so you
need to judge this as a man or woman
watching this yourself that where do I
want to find that balance between okay
this is good enough and good enough can
definitely be a lot no one's saying you
need to settle
um but just be realistic and not aim for
too much about that
um and then obviously there's other
issues like Maher like a lot of sisters
equate their own self-worth with Mahar
and again although it's their right
Allah makes it very clearly that there's
more Baraka in like lower Mahar and you
know cheaper marriages
um but what do you think about that
um I think that
it like when people ask for Maher and
like oh how much is my head or whatever
I feel like
women
at least the ones that I know who are
like really reasonable they say it
depends on the men right it depends on
the guy's income we have to take
everything into account not just
50k and that's it like settled that's my
worth that's how much I'm getting I'm
not no lower than that like no you have
to look at how much the guy makes if
it's gonna make a dent in him or not
because Miss Keen you're just gonna take
money away from this guy who runs 10K a
year but
um
yeah
you're just all about the Benjamins it's
clear that it's not even money
necessarily right we want to make that
clear that the mud can be something else
too
um so sister fluffy is right that it's
not always about the money in the sense
that you have to know what his means are
and you need to know where to draw the
line let's say he has super high
religiosity but he can only afford a
lower mahara than what you are expecting
then you need to make that judgment call
praise the color all that type of stuff
but also doesn't need to be money in and
of itself but uh bro do you do you want
to pay a 50k modeler
that's funny
um
so
something people need to understand is
it really strongly said and I asked my
Sheikh about this and he affirmed it it
really strongly seems to be the case
that Allah he encourages the men to give
Allah and he encourages the women to
take a little you know and that's very
beautiful because on both sides you have
a very giving man and on the other on
the other end you have a woman that
she's okay with a little bit she doesn't
require a lot she's not super high
Maiden she doesn't need a lot I think in
the end the matter should be something
that is is low right and reasonable for
what he makes so he makes a hundred
thousand dollars a year a ten thousand
dollar matter I don't think it's too too
crazy to be honest that's only what ten
percent of what he makes in one year
um I don't think that's something crazy
if you want to do three percent yeah you
know you could do that as well and
pardon my camera I don't know bro I'm
not feeling well today
what how's the memory card
the like the SD card for the camera yeah
it's not in there it hasn't been in
there forever if it's in there then that
doesn't happen I try that too
so so I should put it back in is what
are you saying oh okay I'll be back
you're using a capture card
yeah okay bro be my guys bro take your
time okay I'll be back so brother Karim
asks are you married Daddy and Rami I
don't know what that means but I am yeah
that's that's hella sauce bro come on no
um
yeah Rami is married
get fired a wife he looking I think
no comment
no comment no this means yeah no comment
come on now this is not about me to air
my personal affairs
she means 158 Subs no she means 50k like
a dollar sign I don't think she's on my
subscribers
but again who knows because you are
looking for a man of dawah so if he has
50k subscribe
another age-related question how old is
this woman again I don't think that's
that's necessary
to answer
but let's see pesos so we're talking
about pesos or dollars
in Peru we don't use pesos
um that's a Mexican thing
I'm not Mexican but right no I'm not
Mexican I'm not I'm not gonna name any
names but when anho was here in Canada
someone very close to us thought that he
was Mexican
like just because it triggers us so much
at least me all my family if we get
called Mexican Latinos in general it's
like oh my God that's
the only thing you know
so Mufti menk asks how do you get
married if I barely go out
what would you say to the sister Flavia
oh my goodness they're asking how you
would get married if they barely go out
so whatever
um
I so
I would say if you have a Muslim family
that'd be great maybe get arranged but
in my case since I don't leave my
basement I do have my tick tock
and I just post on there
you know whatever comes it comes
I don't even have to go
DMs
I don't answer to any of them though
because I just I can't be bothered
because none of them have been great
um so you just you have like all the
abundance at your fingertips that's what
you're saying yeah like listen if you
guys are gonna
you know propose in DMS it has to be
like chat GPT style everything your age
no
no like no sending let me let me let me
put this up we keep talking like
um what I mean by chat GPT style is none
of this
yeah none of that oh that is not like
anyone who signs just like sound like
I'm sis mashallah beautiful
you're not gonna get an answer
like we only answer to those who say
like you know who are genuine who look
genuine in their in their things and uh
usually I respond to those saying sorry
brother not looking
because it's true it's true sorry
brother you don't even say walaikum
assalam oh no I say
I was like come on now he's just going
straight for the rejection because I
feel bad like just leaving them with the
whole paragraph and then like they've
said what they're studying and how old
they are they're just like aired no I
feel bad that's why I just say okay it's
not like a brother no can't do Buckaroo
that's it
keep it moving yeah
ask her if the husband has to be older
listening you would have you would have
noticed that she said that child GPT has
negative res what do you think about
that
actually I've made a CV
with tab GPT you don't need risk for a
TV though
I mean like uh I just did one like as a
marriage CV oh really but I didn't I
didn't send it to anyone don't give me
no I don't send none
but it did come out pretty well can I
how's it looking though
you tell me man
no glitches I think you got a little bit
darker bro
um could be lighting yeah
I'm Delight you don't have to fix it bro
it's fine
I said dad writes fired where are you
from
I'm from Canada
I'll leave it at that
bro billow's out here just come on
would any of y'all marry your cousin oh
I want to know this
uh not a specific one but in theory I
wouldn't have a problem with it why'd
you say not a specific one because I I
feel like that would be weird
well any of my female cousins thinking
oh my God he's talking about me or
something like that
do they watch us I don't know
okay what about you sister Flavia all my
cousins are ten and six and three so no
so that's a little sauce
um why do you dislike the red pill
oh
like let's see just goes completely
against the Sun the thing that I dislike
the most about the red pill is that a
lot of the guys who are really deep into
it say that it's okay if a man cheats
and it doesn't and it's not okay for
women cheats
which is completely bogus to be honest
and
um that women are objects to them
basically it's like and out bye that's
it you know they don't like the aspect
of marriage because it holds them down
and
and yeah it is toxic masculinity I hate
using that word but it is that's the
definition of toxic
I mean you you wait you lasted at least
one hour before you pulled that out
though so that's fine we'll give you a
pass if someone comes as a guest and
says toxic masculinity within like the
first like five minutes that's a red
flag
oh that's crazy definitely because like
there's so many other ways to articulate
your thoughts than use a shaming tactic
like toxic masculinity or something like
that
um how we looking bro are you confino
you're muted bro
yeah pretty confident
so without letting this completely go
into a marriage conversation because the
point of next week's stream was supposed
to be talk about can men and women be
friends let's still steer back to the
education thing because there's a couple
more questions that we get a lot uh of
the Amazon asking
um but before we do do any of y'all have
anything to say regarding the education
talk bus far
no nothing I can think of
mm-hmm what about you no not really okay
um let me pull these up so now if you
want to take over the floor while I pull
up the rest of the questions
okay now he's inshallah
um
there was something I was going to say
oh yeah people keep commenting or at
least one guy keeps commenting you know
red pill doesn't go against Islam
um it absolutely does 100 absolutely
does and what do you mean by red pill
you know if by red pill you mean the
truth okay whatever but if by red pill
you mean the actual you know I'd say
pseudo philosophical movement and
ideological movement that prescribes
that men should act a certain way and
women should be a certain way 100 goes
against Islam because this is not
something that you know these are not
things the things they teach are not
things that Islam would allow in some
examples are what the sister said
um and another example I would actually
say the the way in which they do
polygyny the way in which they argue for
polygeny is that I should be able to
sleep with whoever I want how is that
Islamic
it's very very understanding
okay bro I got the question
what are your thoughts on going to
education and not compromising uh free
mixing being something that we avoid so
this is something that a lot of Muslims
are struggling with
well I mean this is just the downside of
living in the west anywhere you go
there's going to be the opposite gender
even in most workplaces 99 of them
unless you choose a field that's like
mainly done by women or mainly done by
men
um and only people in your field are in
that room then you know you're going to
come across opposite gender that's life
all right so that's just living in the
world I get that but what about like it
being a necessary and something that we
can avoid if possible
that's a good question and I think
that's the only
valid
um contention you know people can have
with education but the thing is it
wouldn't be only for women it would be
for men as well I think that's something
that people really miss you know unless
working is seen by Scholars as an asset
or sorry School unless school is seen as
a necessity for working and a man has to
work to provide
um you know there's no making the
argument only for only for against women
and and only men can go to school
um bro do you have any questions
yourself
do I have any questions myself any
questions about anything you get
regarding education anything like that
if not by all means let me know I'll
just keep going yeah nothing I can think
of the law okay can I just squeeze
something in please
I am not a feminist I saw someone say
that I was a feminist and I have a
feminist mentality I am not a feminist
just like to stay together you don't
have to you don't have to clear your
name
I don't think anyone here knows you're a
feminist just by how you look I mean can
you technically be a feminist necklace
I'll be sure sure I'm not I'm not saying
you can't right we don't know what's
what's behind the veil if you think
about you know equality and all this
nonsense but I think that by and large
most hobbies are not feminists at least
even a lot of hijabis that I know sure
some of them might have that but the
ones that are at least wearing it by
choice like yourself because I know no
your mom's not forcing you your family's
not forcing you we talked about your
modesty journey into Islam in the live
stream so any of you that hasn't checked
that out link the description check that
out
um so I know for a fact because it's by
choice for you and many sisters that are
by choice usually they're not forced to
wear hijab so they can't usually
secretly be a feminist you know what I
mean exactly
mm-hmm but what were the comments saying
yeah somebody just said that I am a
hidden feminist and I was like No just
because I don't like red pill doesn't
mean I'm a hidden feminist hmm I don't I
don't like red pill I don't know if that
makes me a feminist too
um Okay cool so next question is going
to be
um let's say that there are ways to
avoid
um Haram in University right me having
gone to University I can answer this to
Sister Flavia you're currently in
University right
and Rami also having been in University
what would be the tips and advice for
Muslims and Muslim us to keep at the
Forefront of their minds to navigate
this I want to say sexual Marketplace
but sure University but it kind of is
because there's just men women a lot of
stuff happening behind the scenes and
Residences that I'm sure you guys know
what we're talking about so what would
the advice be from you guys
do you want to answer first
take it away
um
my first advice would be lower your gaze
and keep your head down
um avidly you have to literally go out
of your way to avoid the opposite gender
you have to go out of your way to make
sure that
um you're you're not sitting beside them
you know maybe find a place where there
are two guys you know beside you and sit
in between them or you know if there's a
guy in the second seat from the end sit
right beside him on the end or
um you know sit study do most of your
studying at home not in the library
where there are other women go to your
classes other than that you know leave
um and do your studying at home these
these are things you actually have to
actively work it's going to be an active
Jihad essentially it's not going to be
something where it's like I'm not going
to do a positive action that's not the
case you actually have to do many
positive actions to avoid
um you know the opposite gender in
talking with them and something I would
say be very very diligent in uh
communicating your your Islamic belief
and boundaries you know if someone comes
and tries to shake your hand don't give
in
just saying I'm a Muslim you know I'm
not allowed to shake hands with the
opposite gender and if they want to cry
about it let them cry about it are they
going to go to the dean say he didn't
shake my hand you know are you going to
get expelled for that no so be very
clear and upfront about your your
religion even if it's something that you
see as small right because we see we
might see it as small but Allah I might
see something that is huge
so tldr are you gonna fear the dean or
the Deen you know what I'm saying I love
that bro but let's say we go back to
that same analogy of Toronto for things
that you can't avoid one of the things
that I've personally done is anytime I
have like an anatomy lab or anything
where it's a little bit more Hands-On I
try to tell my props and Tas very
directly that this is who I am this is
what I believe in this is what I stand
for and again they're gonna bro if they
want to think you're radical let them
think you're radical but you got to do
your part and I told them that if there
is a way to arrange me with only like
male partners for projects and
assignments especially the Hands-On
stuff because we're all women today in
the west no touch barrier same with men
but just you know outside of Islam No
Touchberry whatsoever you know so me
taking these preemptive measures is it
is it something that's easy no because
these are never easy conversations and
matter of fact expect some type of
pushback or them asking like why why
does this you know I've never been asked
this and then you can you can say it as
it is you know I've had other times
where if I was working a job or
something I had to say like can I take a
break at this time to pray you know
um and they're like oh there's Abdul
working here for six years Abdul doesn't
pray I'm like okay I'm not Abdul though
is going out for five cigarette breaks a
day you can give me like 10 minutes to
pray it's not the end of the world so
really establishing your boundaries as a
Muslim where Muslim is extremely
underrated and this doesn't mean you
have to do it in a in a very mean or
arrogant or rude type of way but putting
it in a way where you're not
compromising your Dean for anyone or
anything
um but sister Flavia what would you add
to that
I'd say when you're in a lecture hall
just sit at the front so that you can't
look at anyone and nobody looks at you
especially if you're a man so that your
gaze is solely focused on the Prof and
what he's saying
because even I like you know I noticed
myself like when I get bored I just look
around and whatever not even for like
the wrong intentions right but stay
focused stay focused
so it goes both ways it's not just
you're right so I just meant
um and women have that Fitness too
um anything else that you want to add to
that to navigate
um I think that uh University
in the west at least you know it's a
very very good thing to have especially
a degree bachelor's Master's Etc
um you just have to
put your son first at all times because
it can get very dangerous you can get
very misguided with the people around
you especially in University because
there's so much fitna not only you know
the opposite gender being there but even
like the same gender being there with
you know drugs alcohol
etc etc you want to fit in
but stay away from this stuff the shower
next question is would you ask your kids
or try to get them basically to get
married before going into University or
during or after so I would definitely
try my best if they're ready to help
them out you know and get them married
before University because I'm not
sending them to the meat market bro
single like there's there's too much
fitna
um but what would you guys say
um I would say
honestly
it depends on them whether they're
comfortable or not and I'm gonna make
sure that they can communicate to me if
they want to yes or no
um
I do think though that the man should
kind of be
you know I have to look at and see how
my future son is gonna be if he's mature
enough if he looks like he you know has
his stuff intact
because I do understand that you know
this is Case by case and I don't want
him going into a marriage where I know
that he you know hasn't finished his
degree he's not mature enough on this
and this you know given pointers and
whatever but
um yeah I would see how they are and see
how comfortable
the situation is and I support them I
think I agree with you 100 but I also
think like parents to add to that they
sometimes forget the importance of
having a spouse a companion uh an
intimate partner whatever reason you
wanna you wanna bring whatever Avenue
you want to bring to the table because
they're having their needs met physical
emotional spiritual whatever but they've
kind of been out of the game for a while
if they were married for a long time so
they can't establish the empathy with
their kids and they're like oh you know
what you should be able to put your head
down and study you don't need someone
um
definitely
um Mr Yasmin writes get involved with
msas and have Muslim friends this is
huge
if possible obviously but I mean what do
you think just yeah but just avoid the
msas that are very mixed there are some
msas there's like brothers and sisters
are just completely mixed you know
always at the same table always together
going on trips together and that stuff
avoid that
um okay
no do you want to answer the question
bro
what was the question again
are you sending your kids into
University probably if you have the
choice to pick
um before getting into University would
you get them married would it be during
or would it be after I would make it as
easy as possible for my kids to get
married
um as soon as they are ready
um as soon as I think that they are
ready even if you know my my son or
daughter still live with me
um I want them to have Halal and I will
vet you know
um the men for my daughters and um do
maybe a little bit of vetting for my
sons but I want them to wait till you
know they get to an age where they can
do it themselves
um as for school
um I really don't know to be honest I I
can't say for sure I'm gonna have to
think about it and maybe do it on a kid
by Kid basis
does your answer now and this is the
next question does it differ if it's a
brother or sister or like a son or a
daughter
for which part marriage or yeah like
marriage during which time in school
um like the way I would answer it is if
I had a daughter I would definitely want
her to get married before school if I
have the choice
um and I would do my best to find her
like a suitable husband because I know
that the thing with a lot of sisters is
the more older that they get and we're
not going to cap here we're going to
keep it as it is that youth is something
that men take into consideration when
they are looking for a spouse I know
Sister Flavia has her opinions on the on
her Instagram I'm very well aware of
them it's okay we can agree to disagree
um I'm telling you from a man's point of
view that men find youth and beauty and
all this a little bit more attractive
than someone that's older if all else
variables are going to be the same by
and large on them some men might have a
fetish of older women that's okay but by
and large men do that and it's
biologically hardwired because of the
fertility
um but what would you guys say
um my answer wouldn't really differ to
be completely honest I'm not really
worried like I I want my daughters and
sons to get married as soon as possible
that might be you know at uh 17 18 that
might be at 24 25 it depends on the kid
um whether it's a it's a man or a woman
and um I I know this whole thing about
and like me as well you know if I could
if ever if you have the same woman you
know at 30 versus at 25 I'd rather
married the 25 year old if everything
else is the same but you're never gonna
find that you know that's an idealist
situation find me two women that are
exactly the same in all aspects that's
only different age you know that that
it's yeah in theory but it's not
practical it doesn't work so I don't
mind sharing this I don't care I married
older and you know alhamdulillah you
know it's a blessed thing for me not the
fact that she's older but it's there's
no downside to it alhamdulillah so and
plus you can have people that look like
they're 50 at 25 and they look 25 and
they're 50. so
I understand the fertility aspect you
know if you if you that yeah that's
important but um you know as long as
they are
um you know able to conceive or at least
before 30 then you shouldn't have a
problem at all if they're above 30 okay
then maybe you know you got to be
careful if you're if you're right it
might be an issue but um you know it's
available let's see bro you're rocking
that extra Archer following the Sunnah
um the two Muslims went unfiltered
content around me are do you know when
we're getting the website set up uh it
might take a while we are working on it
we're gonna have a rumble for sure
because even for to have like to have
videos on our website we have to first
post on Rumble and then embed it into
our website
okay Jose Mis on home bro I'm sure I'll
be new too oh and Charlie's gonna be
here this Saturday for the live stream
um Sister Sarah asks isn't 17 too young
well it depends on the person
there is a mature 17 year olds and it's
rare yeah but it's possible and they're
a very immature 25 year olds it really
depends on the person that's to be
that's the beauty in Islam it doesn't
put an age it doesn't say at this age
you're ready to get married you know
whether it's old or young it says if you
are physically mentally emotionally
ready and mature then there's nothing
holding you back subhanallah I was just
gonna say that bro like one of the
criteria is physically like you've
entered the age of maturity or puberty
and then other things like mental
physical if thus in check you can get
married inshallah
um but let's follow the law of your land
too you know what I'm saying I don't
want anyone
um from the you know FBI or whatever
watching us
um but sister Flavia how would you
answer that question though
um
I think yeah I have the the same answer
as Rami it depends on situation and
personally I do think that you know
girls should get married a little bit
earlier because it does take that weight
off of their shoulders
um especially once they get into their
25s I know that it's you know that guys
prefer younger girls and stuff
etc etc
um like it's a real fear unfortunately
for women when you're hitting I don't
know maybe
above 25 that you get kind of scared
um but alhamdulillah there are brothers
out there who you know do say yes to
women who are in their you know 25s 30s
um et cetera et cetera
however I do think that having that
emotional support from a partner from a
young age is really really necessary
especially if even if you want to go
into University having that right there
someone who you know can help you by
your side
is 110 better than just staying at home
I feel like at least
um and from my my friends who have been
married while in University they've had
very very good experiences alhamdulillah
so I talk for them as well they say you
know their experiences have been well
so and they have this weight lifted off
their shoulders because they know when
you're living with your parents and
studying I don't know it's a different
kind of pressure that you have versus
when you're with your husband and
studying because it's like oh okay like
you know what if I if I do fail this
class ultimately I'm going to I'm
already married and I'm just going to
have kids so
you think like it takes a lot of the
pressure away it does take a lot of the
pressure away and we like it
it forwards Us in the aspect of we can
choose because a lot of us do go into
University and college with the
mentality of oh I have to get this
because it's a good degree because my
parents want me to et cetera et cetera
but when you're with a husband and he's
already providing for you it's kind of
like okay well I have free roam to study
whatever I want to study right like it
takes that stress away almost exactly
okay I agree with that
um someone wrote I got married in 19 I
was quite immature in many ways but my
husband was stationed in alhamdulillah I
matured within the marriage
I think that's a that's a very good
thing
um yeah okay so just a few more
questions and guys if you have any
questions related to education and
marriage please write them now this is
your chance because we're going to wrap
up the stream soon
um we don't want to hit two hours again
um inshallah but if you want to jump in
quickly on that last comment
um the prophet Muhammad when he married
and she was very young she was very
immature and we could see how she
matured over the years with the
different you know Hadith we have and
the you know kind of story of her life
when she was young you know their
instances were she would follow the
process to see what he's doing see what
he's up to and stuff
um and he would get jealous if he was
with other wives or if you got a gift
from another wife or something like that
but um she she grew out of that as well
you know
um I think that is a great example and
should provide a lot of Hope for for
young women out there especially if they
see like for example things like
polygenius that the worst thing in the
world when you look at you know she had
her jealousy and that stuff but she was
able to get past it as well
there's a very important point that I
want to mention so
and many many of you have probably seen
Tick Tock surreals about this but when
Rockefeller wanted to basically start
this whole working movement and
Revolution he said that I don't want a
generation of thinkers I want a
generation of workers and that taxing
both sexes would basically bring in way
more money and were built upon this
capitalistic society and a lot of people
don't realize is that even the fact that
one man or one parent let's say is the
breadwinner inshallah the man because
that's his responsibility by Allah first
and foremost that almost nine times out
of ten today unfortunately is not even
enough money to keep the household going
and this is something that a lot of
people don't realize that we are kind of
for a lack of a better word embedded
into a matrix and if we can escape that
then alhamdulillah I can profess from
Allah and being just Slave To The Matrix
but if we can't then it's almost
unavoidable so that's why I think that
when around me said that it's kind of
like if she has to work sure it's very
powerful because most cases today she
does have to work unfortunately unless
the man can provide enough for her not
to work I rarely see a couple where the
man makes enough to basically carry the
whole team and the woman still wants to
work whereas I see more cases where it's
like out of necessity
yeah
uh so what I mean do you want to put
some of the questions up we got a lot of
questions
um five okay one second
inshallah
sister fluffy do you want to answer this
well let me post them up what if I don't
want to get married genuine question
it's not like you're allowed to not want
to get married and you don't have to get
married right it does complete half of
your Dean but it's not a must
and if that if you want to be career
focused that's completely fine as well
um just know what you're getting into
so um I do have a few questions here a
lot of the questions are stupid I'm
sorry like I'm I'm struggling to find
good ones and taking time because a lot
of them are dumb and very you know
personal to people so
um this is a good one how to deal with
pronouns in uni listen they're gonna say
you need to use my pronouns or else you
know you're basically violating me and
my feelings and what I believe and it's
an active kind of transgression against
me just return the same thing listen I
identify as a Muslim and Muslims have
very particular beliefs one of those
beliefs happens to be the fact that when
you're born a male you are a male you're
born a female you are a female and
there's no difference between or there
should not be a difference between sex
and gender
um I know you guys differ with that and
I can respect your opinion but I'm sorry
you cannot force me to refer to you as a
certain thing you know I don't come to
you and say you need to refer to me as
you know the best Muslim in the world or
the the most attractive person in the
room or you know I don't say you have to
refer to me as these things so watch
should have to refer to you as something
you might even what if I generally
thought I was the smartest person in the
world you know I I genuinely think I am
am I going to go to everyone and say you
need to refer to me as this no that's
not fair
um what if there are a lot of doctors
have you know the all the doctors they
earn their their their doctors say earn
their PHD they earn their medical degree
until they earn the term doctor if I
come and identify as Doctor you know
give me a term of respect call me doctor
you know that's very disrespectful to
the doctors out there and I'd say it's
very disrespectful
um for a man to identify as a woman
never having struggles of a woman and a
woman to identify as a man never having
the struggles of Amen
[Music]
no that one's for me that one's for me
don't answer don't worry that one's for
me okay um did she miss deals on um if
it was Aisha Adan
um sure she didn't pray clearly but
that's actually the Sunnah of the public
to delay Isha so if anything she's
trying to get that extra inshallah so uh
asks would y'all marry a girl from uni I
mean just me and Romney sister Floyd is
going to answer that you get a man from
uni sure
yeah
you okay you would why not okay while
you're both in University
well we're both in University
I I just have the the thing of
like we could get married it's just that
where am I gonna live if he's you know
you know just a part for me I don't
really like long-distance things I find
that it's so like I feel ugh my parents
had that and it's like I felt bad for
them so honestly I can't deal with a
long distance thing what do you what do
you define as long distance
long distance is like me it's like 30
minutes one hour
pretty long distance and if like you can
only see each other a few times a week
or maybe even once uh no I can't deal
with that um
preferably you guys are out of school or
he's out of school
and then you guys are living together
best combination is when he's out of
school but she's in school exactly one
has to study
okay
um Rami what do you think
um what I marry is someone near me I
would I would marry sister in uni
um okay uh let's answer this question
how do I deal with prayer times I work
or school very simple there's study
rooms placed in the library there's
there's gonna be places for you to study
for you to study what I was saying for
you to pray it's a choice sometimes an
airport and I still till this day yeah
that was was okay what are people gonna
think what are and I just don't listen
to it I don't cave into it I just make
wudu and I just pray in the corner find
the cable Direction it's that easy it's
just a choice you know you can make as
many excuses as you want but when it all
comes
time to Salah either you pray which
Allah says Salah is but at times they're
fixed they're not things that we can
delay unnecessarily obviously we can
combine and shorten if traveling but I'm
not talking about that if it's work or
school we should pray on time
cancel the question to ask
can you guys give me tips on life I'm a
young man going into high school with a
lot of fitna in this world so we got
middle schoolers watching us about a lot
of uh
what would you say
um
as someone who went through it uh just
stay away from the girls
um the girls are will try and approach
you
um you know if you're a uh you know a
good looking guy attract a guy an
outgoing guy and sometimes when you're
religious actually no the non-muslims
will approach you they'll see it as
something that's exciting so stay away
from them be very clear very very clear
and blunt even even if you hurt their
feelings or whatever and they hate you
after who cares you know I'm sorry
that's life
um keep keep learning Islam and for you
know whatever amount of hours you're
putting into school put at least 10
percent of of that time into learning
Islam and you'll be good inshallah sure
next question how do we convince parents
to raise their daughters with homemaking
skills most don't teach them uh any for
some reason so the reality is that kids
rarely go based on what you say they go
based on what you do and we're all
creatures of imitation so if that's what
you want then that's who you should
become if you're not that and you just
tell them to do this and you're not
necessarily the best Homemaker let's say
you're not really cooking cleaning
you're raising your voice at your
husband being disrespectful is the type
of woman that you are going to be your
kids are going to be receptive to that
and that's what they're going to mod and
emulate when they're older however if
you want them to be a certain way the
best advice is that you should be that
example for them
um because even if you tell them
something they're always going to go
based on what they see you do
um but sister fluffy you can you can
give me your opinion on that two of the
difference
um I think Hmm
I mean you could do the the way my mom
did it she just wouldn't cook a day and
she'd be like father go ahead do it or
my grandma would just like put me in the
kitchen and she was like you have to
learn this come with me and I would cook
the salad you know I'd watch her do it
and alhamdulillah like it's skills that
I think that every Muslim like not like
just girls even right
oh don't don't don't say that though
don't be like life skill
because
like if you're
if you're bro food every single day
broccoli chicken and rice
you're gonna get bored you're gonna get
bored obviously there is QuickBooks but
it's better to learn from from your
parents and stuff it's nice spend time
with them inshallah
so sister Flavia what were you what were
you doing before Tick Tock because I
don't have Tick Tock but I'll be a stick
talk
I was in high school and I was just
doing my own thing well actually we're
in quarantine and I just started doing
tick tocks and stuff so
yeah I was just chilling before
um
Rami is not married someone said he's
married
I am married Rami make it clear bro for
them
I am married okay you're married but
like are you unavailable or are you
still looking
that wasn't the question
oof okay
uh will you have sneako on again if
Allah won't inshallah but I don't know
about that to be honest
um okay cool any last questions let us
know someone wrote must take shahada who
must take charge oh oh no this this
brother asked
um invite him on the stream inshallah
reach out to us on the thing please
let me put my Instagram right here
DM me please I'm going to send you the
streamer link and then we can we can
radicalize it inshallah yeah now
to be fair to be fair you know this is I
I saw his comment before he asked what's
the best way for a Christian to come to
Islam
um and that's the only reason I know he
wants to uh accept Islam now this could
be right this could be a random person
trying to troll it's always possible but
we will become the best sure like you
know sincere wants to accept the snap
damn me bro inshallah you got a few
minutes before we wrap it up have you
guys ever had someone who's trolling
about their Shadow on here no no not yet
but it's still not yet it's still open
to like being a possibility
we have this innate fear that someone's
gonna come flash themselves on stream
and I remember talking to Rami about it
I was like if this happens like what do
we do because we know a YouTuber who is
a streamer as well a Muslim dog YouTuber
and he had that happen to him
[Music]
we can make them like show their face um
to us in the in the room before
DM me bro put your money remote is
inshallah we would love to host you
shallow
someone said use a stream delay I was
thinking but you guys want to look at
live chat a going to make insta to DM
okay in that case just just comment your
email here bro I'll just email you the
streamer link let's keep it simple yeah
I want you registering for a social
media app and be responsible for all the
fitness you're gonna get into just
because of this
because anyone that doesn't have social
media please if you made it this far do
not get it it's not worth it
you know I mean do you want to put up
some other questions bro while I email
him oh yeah sure inshallah
feel free to just paste your
your email
all right
um how do you guys do your podcast is it
on Zoom or something like that so we use
stream yard right now to do um
you know the virtual podcast
did you guys get involved in that I'm
saying uni what were your experiences
like not really to be honest
um
other than going to German
and praying in the measure that never
really got involved
what about you guys
nope
too much harambro going on I was talking
to someone about this yesterday that a
lot of these events or Muslim events but
they're not Islamic events and there's a
difference
you know
bro come on now
he's gonna he's gonna say oh I have to
make a new email to send it to you no no
if he says that well that's it that's
that's the clear song
yeah where's anho he's traveling right
now it's like 3am 4 am from
okay I'm gonna go back to Instagram
there we go I got a request
and
he said I sent it
assalamualaikum brother fired
I don't know this is this you bro this
this looks like a legit like
how do you have 1800k 1800 followers I
don't think this is you no no it's
probably not no because someone just DM
me salaam alaikum brother fired
um so I'm just waiting on this DM right
now
he said he sent it I don't know if he
means the diam or his email in the chat
um is buying a Supercar Haram I'm not
that I'm aware of but you should go ask
a scholar
oh he said he sent it in this chat what
the hell bro
yeah please paste your email again bro
sometimes the chat like it blocks out
certain things bro whatever is your
email
and then put a space and then put at and
then another space and then Gmail or
Yahoo or whatever
and then.com or whatever
bro this is the most delayed shahada
ever come on
a lot of Baraka though for the week
oh you guys are gonna do one right now
yeah that's what we're waiting for oh
it's coming he sent it
okay and then what is it uh uh what
Adrian Adrian Ramos 92 bro that's you
just made that right now bro don't lie
foreign
bro come on now you put it there like a
gamertag like I'm just supposed to add
you
oh Gmail okay bro is it.com.ca come on
I'm not trying to be a hard ass but
we got to be specific now I think we
should assume it's not calm bro let's
see
just send it just send it to both and if
someone else joins whatever
two Shadows bro you said.com okay done
now when you do come please make sure
that if you are a brother like your name
suggests
um
actually you know I don't even need to
tell you that
maybe it's Adriana
nah come on I'm joking I'm joking
oh someone's just spamming.com
appreciate you guys
is tax evasion Haram
of course bro what type of question is
that you're supposed to obey the law of
the land that you live in unless it goes
against the dean
see
so sister fluffy had a random question
for you so yeah given that you're a
gamer have you had good experiences with
men
and their idea of you being a potential
wife being a gamer or do you think that
this has been a deterrent to them
um I won't answer what the gamers your
your friends on online obviously they're
gonna find that okay
um honestly
I don't I don't a game two often that's
the thing like if I do it's usually just
with friends okay yeah we got Adrian in
the chat oh there we go
hey Adrian how's it going bro how's it
going bro good how you doing good good
all right so why don't you tell us a bit
about your story
um race Christian pretty much my whole
life
uh stopped going to church around 18 and
a few years ago I had a friend who
converted to Islam and
I always ask them about it like I always
would just check like hey are you still
I would ask do you still practice Islam
and you'd always tell me yes and um
it just caught my mind and it really
interested me and
uh later earlier this year or I guess
late 2022 I'd really gotten into some
issues and
I just found myself on a uh
on a map praying to God screaming for
for God's help and
I noticed that in Islam there's also
similar like different prayer mats and
it just kind of it shocked me and so I
ended up buying a Quran
um wow just became more interested in
the three Muslims Channel and yeah
I was expecting to get on stream today
sorry
no worries that's that's a very
beautiful story so with that being said
no point in delaying it let me share my
screen
uh so have you seen a shahada before do
you know how it goes
I've seen seen it on your stream but um
I know it's I haven't gone through one
before no okay all right so and that's
all that's all that matters if you've
seen it before we're gonna go through it
together so first I'm just gonna ask you
six very simple questions just to make
sure that you have the basic academic
beliefs in line before you accept Islam
so firstly do you believe that there's
only one God worthy of worship with no
Partners no Sons no daughters no
Associates I do perfect and do you
believe in the angels that God describes
in the Quran I do and do you believe in
the prophets and The Messengers that God
has sent to the world like you know
Abraham and Moses and Jesus and the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him yes
perfect and do you believe in the
Revelation that Allah has sent with
these prophets like the Quran the
original gospel the original Torah and
so on and so forth
I do yes perfect
and do you believe in
um destiny and decree from God
yes and lastly do you believe in life
after death in the day of judgment
I do okay perfect so now you're just
gonna repeat after me in Arabic and I
have the words on the screen here for
you okay can you see the screen
okay okay perfect so say Ash hadu
and LA
amla ilaha
illallah
Anna Anna muhammadan muhammadan
rasulu
perfect now you're just gonna repeat
after me in English
say I bear witness I bear witness that
there's none worthy of worship that
there is none worthy of worship except
for Allah except for Allah and I bear
witness the night bear witness that the
prophet Muhammad that the Prophet
Muhammad
is the servant is the servant and
messenger of Allah and messenger of
Allah
so that's that's how easy it is to
become Muslim you are officially our
brother in Islam now alhamdulillah thank
you of course
um how do you feel bro how do you feel
so great
um
I think it's been a long time coming
um I kind of
have been putting off on just because
I've felt like there's so much that I
need to know and there's so much that I
need to learn that
um
I almost don't feel like I don't know I
didn't feel like I was even qualified to
do a shahada but
um
I won't let me explain about this
religion and uh just feeling my feet wet
and is the first step so yeah
alhamdulillah sister Flavia what advice
would you have for brother Adrian
because I'm sure at one point you felt
like this is taking on a lot you know
did I do it prematurely am I ready to be
a Muslim because once you do the shahada
you kind of it's It's it you know yeah
yeah
um brother Adrian just like say
I'm the lion Muslim now all your sins
are forgiven everything from the past is
in the past but my
my advice to you is to take stuff slowly
okay don't burden yourself with a lot of
things at once because you will find
yourself getting overwhelmed right and I
a lot of people say this and um it's
true right I even feel overwhelmed
sometimes with the amount of information
that people give me and I've been three
years a Muslim right and I still feel
that today
and um I could tell you that even born
Muslims feel that way sometimes as well
so take your time
study the dean study you're you're going
to get more knowledgeable with time
and inshallah like you have a you have a
good road straight path thank you
and um we're definitely gonna connect
afterwards now that you and fight have
exchanged emails and Shout out we can
grab your number we can make a group
chat and we actually have um the three
Muslims Discord I don't know if you've
joined it or not but you can do that I
actually have dedicated Brothers in
there
um who will answer any question you have
and help you with it and also you know
provide a community because one thing
we're really big on in Islam and I think
Muslims really really need to work
um that was not a funny joke by the way
oh yeah literally something that Muslims
really I think need to work on is
building a good Community for reviews
like yourself so that's something that
we're looking to do so I'll send you the
links to the Discord you can join in
we're going to take good care of it I
mentioned you are a brother in Islam it
might seem a bit scary now but I promise
you it's it's really not that difficult
you know the prophet peace be upon him
um a man came to him once and he said
you know what what should I do for Islam
and the prophet saw him he told him you
believe none worthy of worship except
Allah in the prophet Muhammad as the
last messenger of Allah that's the
shahada you just gave that's the
testimony right you just testified to
secondly is that you pray five times a
day and I know someone who doesn't pray
five times a day hearing that is like oh
that's difficult but imagine I said five
different points in the day you're gonna
sit down for two three minutes and
you're gonna meditate that wouldn't be
something that's difficult really and I
know you've probably seen how Muslims
pray it's very it's kind of like
recharging your battery throughout the
day you got to disconnect you say Allah
God is greater than everything else
right that's what Allahu Akbar means God
is greater than the work in school and
you know family stresses and whatever
and you get to focus on you your
connection with him and pray so you know
the first and the second thing just the
shahada I praying five times a day
um fasting the month of Ramadan
uh giving two and a half percent of your
you know your savings in charity to help
the poor and if you can once in your
lifetime if you can physically and
financially afford it you go to uh Mecca
and you do what is called hygiene I can
tell you about that um but it's a very
beautifully spiritually enlightening
Journey so back to the Hadith the
prophet said these five things to me
just five things
you know throughout your life
and the man said I'm only going to do
that and nothing else
and the prophet peace on him he said if
he if he's straight stays true to that
if he actually does those five things
consistently and he doesn't do like
excessive evil then he will go to Jannah
that is what the prophet peace told them
yeah peace be upon him told you know us
in the Hadith as well so it might seem
like it's a lot now and even maybe the
five things I read off you're like oh
how am I gonna do this and that I
promise once the time comes and you've
been doing it like for a few days or for
a year even fasting you know after five
six days your body gets used to it it
will be very beneficial and it will it
will not be difficult for you inshallah
so Rami just real quick this is what
people are commenting
what the heck and someone wrote It's
because you need to set it to stay
active forever the setting just like
maybe maybe sister Flavia knows more
about this course yeah you're a gamer
yeah you need to activate it okay um
brother Adrian I saw that your Quran
says in Spanish oh English I think it
was just oh English I thought it was
Spanish
foreign
so brother Adrian do you have any last
minute questions for us even though we
don't want to overwhelm you but maybe
there's something on your mind right now
that you were hesitant asking do you can
take the time now
um I think I might just try and go
through the Discord
um
see about any mosques in the community I
found one nearby
um I'm not really sure how the the hours
work or if it's a similar
um I guess I can look online to check
that out but
um right now I'm good you guys have my
email YouTube I think uh blocking it
when I was trying to send it yeah
because
um I had to like yeah I sent it
um but Mila bless you bro you're gonna
be in our duas everyone make Dua for
Adrian tonight whatever time zone you're
in that he stays steadfast in the dean
inshallah man that he stays on the right
path I mean I mean I mean all right
it's been an hour almost two hours time
I think we're probably good to you know
begin to to close the stream off
inshallah
inshallah all right so um uh while we
just wrap up we'll let brother Adrian go
unless you have any final questions for
us we'll touch your base afterwards
inshallah make sure that you are uh
taken care of and you know in every
aspect awesome thank you thank you
everyone of course thank you for coming
on last minute bro we appreciate it we
really appreciate you bro take care God
bless
um and sister Flavia do you want to
answer the question right now that
they've been waiting the entire stream
for should women be educated if they
haven't gotten it already
um
should women for the West it's probably
the best if you're not married yes but
it's not a necessity in Islam to be
educated university-wise just learn your
fault stuff and Michelle you'll be good
what about you bro
um
I would say first and foremost the most
important thing is that you learn Islam
it's an obligation upon every Muslim to
learn their religion to learn Islam and
if you have things hindering you from
doing that you should get rid of those
things and focus on learning Islam it
will benefit you it'll benefit your
family it'll benefit your children
uh and there's basically no reason to
not learn Islam so everyone should learn
stuff first and foremost after that
um I'm not going to say they should or
shouldn't
get an education I think we we
definitely need people both men and
women who are educated in different
fields you know female nurses female
most nurses are female you know a
doctors dentists and so on and so forth
um even you know female chiropractors if
a woman has back issues I would not want
a man touching her to uh to help her
with that
um there are certain levels of
permissibility if it's by necessity but
it would be better if we had you know uh
women working for our women
these drums
I have one question for sister Flavia
but I'm going to save it for next
Wednesday inshallah when we do the next
stream
um but if you guys have nothing to say
inshallah around me bro you can wrap it
up all right everyone who joined may
Allah bless you guys please make dot for
our new brother and Islam brother Adrian
and with that being said